you're so great at at deadpan and and
generous
you are you really are terrific you
could we could put you on a time machine
you could go back and be
a huge silent movie star just with the
expressions that you make
with uh your incredible mug and uh
you talk you you say in your book
paddle your own canoe which is terrific
book you say that you learned deadpan
uh at church as a kid is that true
yes i i was an altar boy and then
eventually was promoted to
uh the position of lecter which means
they love that one well they trusted me
you know in hindsight they're probably
kicking themselves but
i got to get up and read a couple of
readings from the gospel to the
congregation before
i was elected you get to read some some
selections yeah i mean it's it's my
first audience and you know
it quickly dawned on me you just come
across a sentence like
jesus did come unto the people
and if you if you read that sentence
with enough gravitas
your cousin is doubled over laughing but
nobody is the wiser nobody knows what's
going on and your cousin's happy you get
the laughs and
but then you get the accolades from the
old ladies are like that was very
very effective yeah
[Laughter]
everybody wins is what you're saying you
win win and when when
jupiter's where it's up yeah uh you're
all you
said you were also i couldn't believe
this you were exposed to pornography
in church you say that in the book
that's right yeah inexplicably
in eighth grade our sunday school uh
catechism they called it ccd
class they brought in this specialist
named sister jesuina one year
in eighth grade and her thing was like
she she shook it up she played us billy
joel's only the good die
young to show us how this
terrible sinner was making fun of you
know of christianity
and then she passed around playboy
and penthouse magazine to a bunch of 12
year olds
what was her point i i don't know i i
think it was
what she there's only two explanations
either she was a terrible pervert
and knew exactly what she was doing
check it out
i mean i think her point was like to
show us you know
like here here's this degraded uh sinful
material
you know can you you may have heard
about this and desired it but once you
see it of course you'll see that it's
terrible
and of course you know of course we're
all like
yeah yeah please make your point uh
your mustache was spinning yeah
all these stereo reviews
the jokes yeah yeah
i can't believe she handed out
pornography that's absolutely
unbelievable it was crazy we were pretty
freaked out and
i mean you know it was the first time
any of us had seen that sort of
uh anatomy yeah it was
quite moving uh we definitely came back
next week for sunday school